>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Good afternoon.
I'm Larry Appelbaum
with the music division.
I'm here once again
with Dr. Ingrid Monson,
Quincy Jones Professor
of African-American Music
at Harvard University.
We had an interesting,
stimulating chat the other day
and I kept thinking
there's more.
There's more to talk
about, more to discuss.
So that's what we're
going to try and do today.
I want to get a sense,
first of all,
for what exactly the
Quincy Jones Professor
of African-American
Music at Harvard does.
What do you do?
>> Ingrid Monson: What do I do?
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah,
tell us your typical
day at the university.
>> Ingrid Monson:
Oh, my typical day.
Well, it depends whether
it's a teaching day,
a meeting day, or
a research day.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Okay.
>> Ingrid Monson: But
usually when, you know,
teaching is very time intensive.
And I spend a lot of time
preparing for courses,
continually trying to
update my material.
So there's a lot of preparation
for the teaching of the courses.
There are then faculty meetings
in which we discuss the progress
of students, deal with what
our curriculum is going to be.
There are departmental
and university committees
of various kinds.
Now, I'm in two departments
so I actually have
two faculty meetings.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Which two departments?
>> Ingrid Monson:
Music and African
and African-American Studies.
And in African
and African-American Studies
I service the director
of undergraduate studies,
which means that I have
office hours every week
where I'm meeting with people
who are majoring in African
and African-American Studies
and try to help advise them
on courses to take or
how to meet the deadlines
that they need to -- need
to complete their degree
in a timely fashion, to
turn their senior thesis
in on time, those
general things.
Faculty members spend
time on search committees.
So, and in search committees
you read the dossiers of many,
many very promising
candidates and then you have
to discuss them and
come, you know,
and meet with your
colleagues and talk about them.
You have to go to
their interview events,
which include talks and
teaching classes and lunches
and so on and so forth.
So there's a lot of stuff
that we do that has nothing
to do with, you know, what we
ostensibly got our degrees for,
which is doing research.
So we're always constantly
trying
to find more time for research.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Of all
those things you just mentioned,
what are the parts of your
job you enjoy the most?
>> Ingrid Monson:
Well, I like teaching.
I love interacting
with the students.
And I love doing my research.
So I would say I
prioritize those two things.
I think I am in the company
of most of colleagues
when I would say that
meetings are my least favorite.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Because
they're not always productive
or because they're
political or what?
>> Ingrid Monson: Well,
they take up a lot of time.
And sometimes you feel
like maybe the meeting
wasn't necessary.
Maybe this could have been
handled in some other way.
Did we really, you know,
have to spend an hour
in a meeting about this?
But this is a common complaint
throughout universities.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Indeed.
So, I want to get a sense for
the trajectory of your career.
How did you get from being
a practicing musician
to becoming an educator scholar?
>> Ingrid Monson: Well,
I was living in Boston
and I was playing in a
number of different groups
after I graduated
from music school,
from New England Conservatory.
>> Larry Appelbaum: You
were a trumpet player?
>> Ingrid Monson: I
was a trumpet player.
I played in the Klezmer
Conservatory Band,
which does Klezmer music.
And that band was
quite successful.
We toured a number of places
and [inaudible] companion
and that sort of thing.
I also played in salsa bands in
Boston and I played, you know,
pickup jazz gigs where we would
organize them in various spaces
and places in the Boston area.
I also was doing
a certain amount
of teaching kids how
to play the trumpet.
So there I was, and you
get tired of touring.
You get tired of traveling.
You get tired of
packing your bag.
And I -- and I felt like I
wanted to be doing more reading.
So I had this thing where
I often did my warmups
where I was reading things.
Other people were watching TV
while they did their warmups,
but I was -- I was doing quite
a lot of reading and I learned
about the field of
ethnomusicology.
I think my time at New England
Conservatory exposed me some
to world music because there
was a man at the conservatory
at that time named Dr.
Peter Row who was a sitarist
and I took a class in North
Indian music from him.
And it -- and it was
-- it was mind blowing.
It was amazing.
And so he was a practicing
musician and taught us all sorts
of things, the bowls, the
verbal sounds that you make
to speak rhythms
in Indian music.
I read Harry Powers for the
time, who was a musicologist
at Princeton who wrote
widely about Indian music.
And so I was very, very
fascinated by Indian music
and that made me, you know,
open to ethnomusicology,
as did playing in Latin
bands in the Boston area,
because that was a --
that opened up a whole
world to me as well.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Can
you talk just a little bit
about that world
that's opened up?
>> Ingrid Monson: What, the?
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah,
how did it open up to you?
How does playing in a -- in
a Latin band or a salsa band?
>> Ingrid Monson: Okay,
so I played in this band,
[speaking foreign language],
and it basically was a
cover band doing covers
of arrangements by
people like Willie Colon
or Celia Cruz or
some Tito Puente.
And we played -- and
there are a mixture
of things in the repertoire.
There were straight
up salsa pieces
for more Puerto Rican
kind of audience.
Then we played cumbias
for Columbians.
We played merengues
for Dominicans.
So I started to leaned
about, you know, different --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Rhythms.
>> Ingrid Monson:
Musical styles associated
with different subsectors
of the Spanish speaking
population in the northeast.
And we did gigs at
Lawrence [assumed spelling].
We did gigs in Boston.
There was a place called The
Latin Paradise and Providence,
in a social club in the Bronx.
And I loved playing the music.
First of all, it's very
trumpet centric, okay.
Secondly, the dancing
that took place
in these clubs was just amazing.
And I found that as a person
with a jazz background I had
to learn a different
sense of time to do this.
And I started to learn about
clave, which is a subject
that had -- that
is very profound,
that goes -- that
goes very deep.
And I think at the time I was
in those bands I only
understood that a little bit.
So I --
>> Larry Appelbaum: So clave
being sort of the heartbeat
of rhythm for a lot of these --
>> Ingrid Monson: Well,
this idea that there's
a syncopated rhythm,
recurring rhythm that --
around which everything
else is organized.
And that there are
elaborations of this pattern
that everybody knows that are
played on the [inaudible] drum
or on the timbales or
what's being played
on the cowbell at
particular times.
And so, you know, it
piques your curiosity.
It makes you want to learn more.
So I was always the kind of
person who wanted to learn more
and I enjoyed seeing
these, you know,
communities of people
gathering for this music.
And it was a world I hadn't
had any experience with before,
but it left me with a, you
know, an open feeling to wanting
to know more about them.
The same thing with
Indian music.
There was, of course, not
as large of Indian community
in Boston around the music
and I didn't really
become a player of it.
But I started going to Indian
music concerts including,
you know, people like Ali Akbar
Khan, who I heard a number
of times and just
was blown away by.
I mean, if you're
interested in improvisation,
it's just the level of
improvisation that goes
on in North Indian music
is truly astonishing.
So I wanted to hear, you know,
so I had eclectic tastes.
I wanted, you know, I solely
by did I like the music or not?
Did it pique my interest enough
to spend more time with it?
So that's why ethnomusicology
became a good place for me.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So
your interest is piqued
in a certain style,
a certain genre.
How do you pursue knowledge,
or even just information
about these styles when
there's not basic reference
materials necessarily?
>> Ingrid Monson: Right,
and that was certainly the
case in the early 1980's.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Ingrid Monson: There was not
much written about Latin music.
There was not -- there was not
that much world music
available in record stores.
I mean, you probably
remember this yourself.
There was this store in Boston
that carried like the Folkways,
Smithsonian collections,
Folkways collection
of world music, and I used to
go in and buy those albums.
And it wasn't like now you can
go online and hear a little bit
of it before you buy it.
You know, you would look at
it, if you liked the cover,
if you thought that the
label was interesting
or reputable you would
-- you would buy it.
So I would just cold buy
all sorts of records.
And that's how I learned about,
in the Time Square
subway station --
>> Larry Appelbaum:
I remember that.
>> Ingrid Monson: In New York.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
I remember that shop.
>> Ingrid Monson: There
was a Latin record store --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Ingrid Monson: That
everybody went to.
And so every time I went
to New York I would go
into that record store
and buy Latin records.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And the guy
who ran it was so knowledgeable.
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I would
just say, oh, I'm interested
in really great tres
players, for example.
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes, well,
here and out he pulls them.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And he'd
go in the back and he'd rummage
through and he'd
pull out six of them
and I would just buy them
based on recommendation.
>> Ingrid Monson: Well, right.
And there was a place
like this in Boston.
It was a record store in
Mission Hill neighbor --
in the Mission Hill
neighborhood of Boston,
and that was a Latin
record store, too.
You couldn't buy that music
at a mainstream record store.
And there weren't things
like Tower Records then.
An evolution started
to happen in the 1980's
with the establishment
of Tower Records
and the apparent
starting of this genre
that becomes called world music.
You have people like Salev Kata
[assumed spelling] emerging.
You have Boba Mall [assumed
spelling] coming to New York.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
All the Afro pop stuff.
>> Ingrid Monson:
Yes, you get the Afro,
a lot of Afro pop stuff, but you
also had the mysterious voices
of the Bulgarian Women,
and I loved that album.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
But how do we account
for something like that?
It's just in the culture.
For some reason that caught
on and sold tremendously well.
And I could never figure out,
like where did people
hear about this?
It didn't get played on
the radio, for example.
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: It
wouldn't necessarily be written
up in the -- in the
mainstream press.
So how do these things
bubble up?
>> Ingrid Monson: Well, there --
well, I think it
depends on the context.
But in the case of the Eastern
European stuff, for example,
there was this Bulgarian brass
band in New York that I found
out about through
my Klezmer circles
when I started graduate
school at NYU in 1985.
And all of those people
had been, you know,
running around collecting
records in the same way
of Eastern European music,
Bulgarian records, you know,
traveling various places,
Yugoslavia, and coming back
with these rare button
accordion, you know,
recordings and things.
And so those community
organizations in New York,
when they heard that
the Mysterious Voices
of Bulgaria were coming
to Lincoln Center,
which I think they did,
I think they played
in Lincoln Center,
they all turned out.
So, in a similar way, when I
played in the Klezmer band,
I mean, this was not a super
huge audience, but the people
who were devoted to it were
seriously devoted to it
and it was moving
to play to them.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Were you
always comfortable playing
in different time signatures?
For example, a lot of this
ethnic music is based on things
that is mother's milk
coming for some --
for people who grew
up in the culture.
>> Ingrid Monson: Oh right.
>> Larry Appelbaum: But for
those of us who were sort
of conditioned by march music
or by standard swing music,
those are different rhythms.
>> Ingrid Monson: They
are different rhythms.
And most of the -- most of the
Klezmer stuff was actually not
in those multiple rhythms.
But members of our band were
deeply interested in the stuff
that was so we practiced doing
things in seven and 10 and 11.
I had a Bulgarian
brass band record
that had all those
time signatures in it.
And, you know, you pra --
it, you know, so it's --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Does
it come easy for you?
>> Ingrid Monson: The
fun of the challenge?
Well, yes, I would practice
it and I would get it.
And what's interesting to me
right now is that amongst,
you know, now many of the clave
rhythms have become more central
in jazz as well.
So, in the old days you
didn't necessarily have
to know clave really well, like
the difference awawa [phonetic]
and koe and a son
montuno or various things.
But now people really
do need to know that.
And people have been doing
clave rhythms in seven.
You get somebody like Dafnis
Prieto, for example, from Cuba.
And so a drummer friend of mine,
Ralph Peterson [assumed
spelling], you know, did a --
was doing, you know, does
a clave thing in seven
that he expects his band
to be able to play to.
So I think doing some of those
more ambitious meters has sort
of come into the consciousness.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
So you somehow morphed
from being just a player, your
curiosity leads you to academia.
>> Ingrid Monson: Well, I
had always been, you know,
a scholarly sort, too.
And you have to -- the other
axis of my upbringing is I went
to high school in Madison,
Wisconsin during
the Vietnam War.
Madison was very much a
hotbed of antiwar activism.
So I met all those people.
I actually had moved
into my high school
when I was a sophomore, and so
everybody else had friends there
from the time they were like in
second grade and I didn't have
as many friends because
I just moved in.
So I went down to
State Street in Madison
and I read all the alternative
papers and, you know,
bought music and listened to it.
And then one of my high school
teachers was very much involved
in some community organizing --
organizations, and
from then I started
in Marxist study
groups of various kinds.
So, by the time I was
a sophomore, a junior,
I was reading a lot of political
stuff about the Vietnam War.
Kind of, you know, the Marx --
reading about Marxism
is really good training
for social theory
actually as it turns out.
And I think one of the
reasons I did very well
as a graduate student is I
had a background in that.
I actually was an economics
major at the University
of Wisconsin and I
took all these courses.
I took George Mosse's [assumed
spelling] history courses.
Harvey Goldberg [assumed
spelling] was on leave
when I wanted to
take his course.
But these are people
who taught sort
of progressive history courses.
And so that was the other
side of my background.
And so I was always
interested in reading deeply
about society and, you know, and
trying to see the relationship
between music and society.
And jazz always had that, you
know, front and center just --
>> Larry Appelbaum:
When you were
in Madison was Richard
Davis teaching there?
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes,
and Richard Davis was
an early mentor of mine.
I think it was in my junior
year there when he came
and I played in ensembles.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
He's the base player
for those who are watching.
>> Ingrid Monson: The bassist.
A wonderful bassist.
And I took his jazz history
class, which he taught based
on the Smithsonian
collection of classic jazz.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Oh, really?
Yeah, interesting.
>> Ingrid Monson: And I
was in ensembles with him
and he was really
nice to me, you know,
and he was very encouraging
to students.
And there was also on faculty
a woman named Joan Wildman,
who was a pianist and had a
very close relationship to some
of the people in the
art ensemble of Chicago.
And so she was, you know, had
an avant-garde orientation.
And between the two of them
I became part of a community
of people playing music at
the University of Wisconsin.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So Roscoe
Mitchell was there, yeah?
>> Ingrid Monson:
Roscoe Mitchell came.
There were some other
people that came as well.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
So, I wonder how much of
this music, and we're talking
about jazz, but other
styles as well,
how much of it is still sort
of oral tradition versus things
that you learned
from reading books
or attending a conservatory?
>> Ingrid Monson: Well,
that's interesting.
When I was coming up, and even
though I went to a conservatory,
at that time there weren't that
many jazz pedagogical materials.
What was available
was fairly minimal.
There were some David
Baker books.
There were -- and so a lot
of the training was not
focused on these books.
I had a course in the
Lydian Chromatic Concept
of Tonal Organization --
>> Larry Appelbaum:
George Russell.
>> Ingrid Monson:
From George Russell.
But really, the heart and soul
of the music really comes
in the oral training.
And also at New England
Conservatory was Ran Blake
and the third stream
department at that time
and they really emphasized
learning things by ear.
And I took a third
stream ear training class
that Hank Esnetsky
[assumed spelling] taught.
And that approach was you
learned your intervals
by learning songs that
begin with those intervals.
And Ran had this, you know,
[inaudible] of Billie
Holiday songs.
And what we would do, we had
little cassette tape recorders
and there would be a song
assigned every week and we had
to sing it back onto
our tape recorder
until we had it in our head.
And there's certain Billie
Holiday songs I will never
forget as a result,
like no more.
You know, so I thought that was
a wonderful way to do things.
But then jazz, we always were
transcribing things, too,
to try to figure things out.
>> Larry Appelbaum: By the
way, what can you learn
from transcribing either
a solo or a composition?
What do -- what's that
process teach you?
>> Ingrid Monson: There
are a lot of things.
First of all, by the process
of translating the sounds
[inaudible] notation can be
very challenging.
And one of the things, in
order to transcribe it,
you usually have
to repeat it a lot.
So one of the things
about transcribing something
is it forces you to listen
to things at a level
of closeness
that you would not otherwise do.
And once you've listened to a
piece enough to transcribe it
into notation, it's deeply
in your head in a way
that it would not have
been if you didn't do that.
There are many schools
of thought on this.
Some people think
that, you know,
just learn to play
along with it.
Ran always used to
emphasize singing,
learning to sing
it before trying
to play it on your instrument.
And that, I think it comes
out of a Tristano kind
of idea about this.
And I think it's
actually very effective.
Now, I find personally if I just
learn it by ear and I go back
to it and I don't play it
or think about it for a year
and I come back, it's sort of
like I have to do it again.
Maybe other people, you
know, it stays in longer,
but I find that if
I don't use it.
So it's nice to have
had it written
down so I can relearn it.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Now,
there are certain aspects,
especially of jazz performance,
or even of recordings,
that embody sound.
It's not just notes.
>> Ingrid Monson: That's right.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
And so, for example,
you can transcribe the notes
that Ben Webster plays,
but how do you get to his
sound, that breathiness, that,
you know, it's like the
sound of someone's voice.
It tells you so much.
>> Ingrid Monson: Absolutely.
And it does.
And I think that brings
up a really key point
about the limitation
of transcription,
is that it gives you two
parameters, rhythm and pitch.
And there are a lot
more parameters
in the fullness of sound.
So, but part of learning a
piece by ear from a recording is
to try to emulate the sound.
So people, as a trumpet
player trying
to emulate Miles Davis'
sound, for example,
or Lee Morgan's sound.
These are things that
people do try to do.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And is
this what you try to do?
>> Ingrid Monson: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Well, was
there somebody that was a model
for you as a trumpet player?
>> Ingrid Monson: Well, no,
I like a number of them.
But, you know, there are always
-- there are a number of people
who are high on my list.
>> Larry Appelbaum: For example?
>> Ingrid Monson: Miles
Davis is high on my list.
Lee Morgan is, I love his sound.
You know, just, I mean, as --
the quality of sound
on the instrument.
I like that rich sound,
dense sound that he gets.
I studied for a while
with Woody Shaw and I
like his playing extremely much.
I mean, it's really hard
to do what Woody does,
okay, you know, so.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Do you mean
harmonically or rhythmically or?
>> Ingrid Monson: Well,
all these incredible pentatonic
patterns that he developed.
I have -- I still have
these exercises of his
that he gave me that I practice.
But the way he was able
to phrase with them.
So I think the other thing,
it's not so much the notes
or even the quality of the
sound, it's a kind of sense
of phrasing that you get -- that
you -- where you try to emulate.
Like, I think that's absolutely
key in Charlie Parker.
I mean, I don't know if
you've ever heard kids
who are just reading Charlie
Parker transcriptions compared
to the ones who've actually
listened to the solos
and are trying to get to the
places where he swallows notes
and accents notes and things,
which are really, you know,
key to sounding anything
like him.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I just
wonder if we're going to get
to the point, sort of a
next level of being able
to notate the more
idiosyncratic aspects
of music production,
of sound production.
>> Ingrid Monson: You
know, I don't know.
I mean, this is a big
debate and, you know,
there have been debates about
this in ethnomusicology.
There's always this thing
about what good is
transcription and what for.
And if you -- if
you sit down a class
and you have 12 people
transcribe the same thing,
you're going to have subtle
differences in all of them.
And then people like Charles
Seeger tried to do things
like the Melograph, where you
see these sound spectrums.
And I look at that and it's
like I can't do anything
with that, you know.
I can't translate a
sound out of that.
At least with notation
I can translate a sound.
I get something that looks
like a sound out of it.
There are people who are doing
really interesting things
about trying to visualize music.
And I'm fascinated by this guy.
There's this guy, I wish I could
remember his name right now,
but he does these elaborate --
he does it by making MIDI --
you know, entering MIDI
parts to everything,
like the Beethoven Symphony.
And there's a guy who does James
Jamerson baselines like this.
Enter it -- he's a
bassist and he uses MIDI
to enter all the notes.
And then you can create
an animation of it
where it moves in
time to the music.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
I've seen that, yeah.
>> Ingrid Monson: And you
can have different colors
and different walls of sound to
try to -- you know, there's --
one of these tries
to -- gives --
you know, make crunchy harmonic
sounds in Chopin visible
through colors on that.
So I think we're always trying
to come up with new ways
to represent music, and
I'm always trying to come
up with new ways to
present music to my students
where they hear more than
they started hearing.
>> Larry Appelbaum: The
other day when you first came
and we were looking through
some of the treasures
in the collection, I showed you
a piece by Wadada Leo Smith.
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
As an example of sort
of non-traditional notation.
And he is a great example of
somebody who is trying to break
through sort of old models --
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And teach
in a way that goes like straight
to the heart, or sometimes
it bypasses the brain.
Antony Braxton is another one
who makes use of
non-traditional --
>> Ingrid Monson: Absolutely.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Notation.
Yeah.
>> Ingrid Monson: And both
of them are very intellectually
engaged in their own way.
I mean, I've, you know,
had the pleasure of talking
with Wadada Leo Smith and
seen him do a presentation
on the [inaudible].
And it's a system.
It's a very clearly,
deeply thought out way
of representing these things,
and he uses it productively
in his own art.
And Anthony Braxton, the same.
All those numbers and
circles and things as titles
of the pieces, he was
very much, very interested
in signs, a very brainy guy.
So, you know, I think there's
a tradition of people trying
to find new ways
of representing.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Thank goodness.
So all of this was sort
of background and context
for you telling me,
or explaining to me,
how you get from being a
player to becoming the teacher.
And I'll preface this part
by asking what do you
think makes a good teacher?
>> Ingrid Monson: A thing that
makes a good teacher is getting
to know your students and
hear them, listening to them.
You may end up arguing with
them about certain things,
but if you don't know your
students you're not going
to be very effective
at reaching them.
And this is why teaching
in a small group
or a small is the
ideal situation.
It gets harder.
The larger the class gets,
the harder it is to get
that same feeling of
back-and-forth and exchange
and really knowing all the
students that you're talking to.
Then --
>> Larry Appelbaum: So do
you teach undergrad and grad?
>> Ingrid Monson: I do, yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And the
undergrad classes I assume
are larger?
>> Ingrid Monson:
No, not all of them.
Some of them are small.
They are different sizes, but
there are courses at Harvard
and things that they
called general education
that tend to be larger courses.
And they've -- I've tried
to teach a couple of those.
For one, I started on R
and B [inaudible] class.
It started out with 17 people
and then when it got --
all of a sudden I had 150
in it when it got approved
for general education.
And those courses are often ones
where we have section leaders
that employ our graduate
students.
So I try to have a mixture
of the larger ones
and the smaller ones.
And even though I prefer
teaching smaller classes I felt
like I should teach
the larger class
because the graduate
students need
to have some experience
teaching as well.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Now,
do you teach those same
classes year after year?
>> Ingrid Monson:
About every other year.
I do -- I do one large
lecture course a year.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And how does
it change from year to year?
>> Ingrid Monson: Oh,
it changes every time.
You know, I do a course
called jazz freedom in culture
and I have noticed a
difference in the knowledge
that people have
coming into a course.
The old expectation in a
jazz course is to teach the,
you know, the full
history of jazz.
I have wanted to have
more recent jazz in it.
You know, I, you know, I've --
lately I've given some thought
of doing it backwards or doing
it in dialogue where I start
with something really
recent before I jump back
to New Orleans and talk about
where it -- where it came from.
Because it's hard to get our
current undergraduate students
to really get into
listening to scratchy 78's.
That's -- they keep
wanting the later --
they keep wanting Miles
Davis and Coltrane.
It used to be that a lot
of people really loved
hearing the avant-garde section
of the course, too.
Now that's a tougher sell.
So I've been trying to juxtapose
some noise in hip-hop with noise
from '60s avant-garde stuff
to show them the relationship
to it, so they just don't
think, well, that's old stuff
and why did people do
that in the first place.
You know, I think of the younger
generation as being adventurous
or of thinking of themselves
as being adventurous,
but then I put on Sun
Ra, Space is the Place,
and they don't know
what to do with it,
you know, kind of at first.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So how --
>> Ingrid Monson:
What is this about?
Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: How
do they process this,
or are they looking
to you to provide --
>> Ingrid Monson: Well, I try
to give them some process.
I have them, you
know, read materials.
Like John Szwed's book is
absolutely wonderful on Sun Ra.
So I assigned the
reading for that.
But usually they haven't
read it before, you know,
they get to the class on
Sun Ra and I'm playing,
you know, materials from it.
And I -- so I just try to --
Give them, you know,
some understanding
about where he was coming
from and why he managed
to create his own
world in a world
that was not necessarily
welcoming to what he was about,
and he did an amazing
job of it actually.
>> Larry Appelbaum: What
are the kind of required --
what's the -- what's the
required reading list
for your classes?
>> Ingrid Monson: It depends --
>> Larry Appelbaum:
What kind of authors?
>> Ingrid Monson: It
depends on the course,
but I always have a Amiri
Baraka, A Blues People.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
It's standard.
>> Ingrid Monson:
Because it, you know,
it's a really brilliant book.
And it has an ambitious
-- it's social theory.
I mean, I have a piece that
I never published but I put
up online called Amiri
Baraka as a Social Theorist.
And he really had this idea
of the path from slavery
to citizenship and the way
African-Americans are feeling
in the world can be
followed through music.
And he drew on, he read
Herskovitz, he read all sorts
of anthropology in it, and so
he's constantly trying to look
at the relationship of
African-Americans to the music,
but also in Blues People
of white people's
relationship to it.
So he talks about
[inaudible] back in there.
He talks about white
beboppers as being as marginal
as African-American beboppers,
but it was a matter
of choice, okay.
Kind of -- that's
kind of how he put it.
So that's -- I have
them read Ralph Ellison.
I have them read Albert Murray.
I have them read books by any
one of a number of jazz scholars
from Scott DeVoe to Gunther
Schuller to, you know,
Robin Kelly's biography
of Thelonious Monk.
I also have them read articles
from journals at the time.
They love actually
reading the articles
from Downbeat during
the civil rights era.
So the, you know, big debates
that were published
in Downbeat Magazine.
Articles by Nat Hentoff,
you know, they enjoy.
At one point when Nat was
still with us, I had Nat come
to a class that we did
on Freedom Now Suite
and we read the debate
and he read the article
and then he was there and
the students were able
to ask him questions,
and they loved that.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
So if people --
if anyone were to make a
Freedom Now Suite for today,
what would it sound like?
>> Ingrid Monson: Well, I think
we're beginning to see some
of what those sounds are in
response to Black Lives Matter.
I've seen it in the
last two or three years.
I noticed a difference in
the attitude of my class
when I taught the
class last spring.
It's now that there
is a movement
on the ground there is a
sense of the younger people
of what is the relationship
to it going to be?
One of the albums that I think
is interesting that has come
out is Terence Blanchard's
Breathless.
I don't know if you've
listen to that.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I have.
>> Ingrid Monson: In which
he's got some spoken word,
things going on.
And the piece Breathless,
the poet, I think --
the title track I think is
really very, very interesting
and he's playing his beautiful
trumpet solos with a band
that is kind of playing
more elaborate versions
of some popular music
groups but,
you know, are absolutely jazz.
He sees used a Cornell West
speech on that and he's trying
to -- in Breathless he's trying
to talk about Eric Garner.
So that's one example.
So I think different
musicians, as things hit them,
are going to inspire new ways.
Now, I was very interested
in Kendrick Lamar's album.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
To Pimp a Butterfly.
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Ingrid Monson: And
what I noticed there,
I've been interested in the
jazz people that are trying
to have some relationship
to the hip-hop world,
people like Glasper.
But in this case it sounded
like a hip-hop or trying
to have a relationship to a
certain kind of jazz sound.
And what I was interested
in is that there were parts
of that sort of avant-garde
saxophone sound.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Kamasi Washington is --
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
One of them, yeah.
>> Ingrid Monson:
Yes, yes, exactly.
I'm not sure Kamasi is
actually on that album.
I think somebody else is on that
album, but I could be wrong.
But anyway, there is this
sense that there is this sound,
there's an assertiveness to
the sound and it has some kind
of relationship to the message
that Kendrick Lamar
is trying to put out.
And so it's putting that
sound world into hip-hop.
This artful, you know, and the
upping the sense of artfulness
in hip-hop, not that it
hasn't always been there.
And I think we'll see artists
coming to different kind
of collaborations
along those lines.
And so Robert Glasper and his
stuff, with amazing singers,
Erykah Badu and others,
there is this kind
of dialogue between the two.
And then what -- and then
I was absolutely blown away
by Beyonce's Lemonade.
Now, I wouldn't quite say
it was putting jazz into it,
but there was a level of
artistic ambition in it
that seemed to me
really informed
by understanding
African-American history
and particularly women's voices
within that that's drawing on,
you know, there's -- there
has been this presence
in African-American studies
since I entered the Academy
in the '80s, these rich
sources of history.
Writers like Toni Morrison,
and examples like Toni Morrison
or Audre Lorde and
things that are --
that people are studying
in deep ways
and that you see them
inspiring a younger generation
of musicians.
So it's going to be
interesting in the next year
when we start getting
some artworks that are --
that will be speaking to
the election of Trump.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
I would imagine so.
>> Ingrid Monson: I think
they're going to blow our minds.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Well, I mean, I guess --
this brings another
question to mind.
Many creative artists
have always had their ear
to the ground of
what's happening
in the culture, you know.
And yet when music
is often inspired
by popular culture it
can reach more people
because of the message, but it
doesn't seem to last as long.
It has a shorter shelf life.
Whereas certain of what --
certain items that we
would consider classics
in jazz are relevant for
a much longer period.
And I wonder whether things
that seize upon what's happening
at the moment, is it
just music of the moment
or does this become
a classic expression?
>> Ingrid Monson:
Well, I think in a lot
of these things they
become classic.
I think a lot of the
popular music stuff became --
I mean, Marvin Gaye's What's
Going On became classic,
Curtis Mayfield, that I do think
a certain number of those works
in popular music
do become classics.
And we're not sure what are
going to become classics
from what's coming out at
this moment and we don't --
we're not sure whether there
will be classics coming
out of it at this
moment in jazz either.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Well, a
fascinating example of that,
for me, is I'd say in the
1960's, certainly late '60s
into the early '70s, a lot
of jazz musicians who wanted
to attract a larger audience,
a more popular audience,
would adopt certain
rhythms and certain sounds,
especially if you look
at Blue Note Records
under the Mizell
brothers, right?
And that stuff did become
popular in its day and then
for a long period
of time was dormant
and then it got rediscovered by
people who started sampling it.
>> Ingrid Monson:
Sampling it, absolutely.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Ingrid Monson: Cantaloupe
Island for one, yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So
it's not always easy
to predict these things,
but it's fascinating how certain
modes of expression are cyclical
and they have a life
beyond a generation.
>> Ingrid Monson: Absolutely.
>> Larry Appelbaum: It can
actually skip a generation.
>> Ingrid Monson: I
think that they do.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
So --
What -- I want you to
talk a little bit more
about your students and, I mean,
you've been at this for a while.
You've been teaching how long?
>> Ingrid Monson: Since 1991.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Okay, more than a minute.
And so, how have your
students changed?
>> Ingrid Monson:
Well, first of all,
when I started I was
closer to their age, okay.
And I felt like my own
understanding of things
in the world and theirs
were not very different.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Okay.
>> Ingrid Monson: And so I could
talk about jazz or popular music
or world music in ways --
You know, that I -- that I felt
were easier to communicate.
Now, over the years then you
become stuck in this role
of you're the teacher and
you have to grade them.
You have to give
them assignments.
You have to, you know, so you
start to become a certain kind
of disciplinarian,
whether you want to or not,
because the nature of the
university is such that you have
to grade them, unless
you're teaching at a school
that doesn't have grades,
in which case then you have
to write lots of letters of
rec -- you know, basic --
you have to write lots
of letters about them.
The students when I started
teaching were more aware
of the real history of the civil
rights movements I would say.
It was in the experience
of their parents rather
than their grandparents.
And they were open-minded
towards a, you know,
wanting to tear down racism
view of teaching jazz.
And white students, black
students, they were open to --
they were open to
that narrative.
I learned in the
first five years
that there would be a certain
group of white students
in the class who would be
resistant to wanting to think
that anything about race
or African-American history
mattered to the class.
Why do we have to
read all this stuff?
Can't we just listen
to the music, you know?
And they were more comfortable
in a space of wanting to turn it
into a technical problem.
And I always felt, you know,
in many cases when I taught
in St. Louis, for example,
there would be very few
African-American students
in the class.
And the poor students who were
there always felt, you know,
sort of, you know, put on
the spot of having to speak
for the entire culture.
And some of them enjoy doing
that and others just, you know,
found it -- found it depressing.
I did get a reputation as
being a sympathetic teacher.
And so I, the more I was there
more African-American students
came to my class and once --
and I really learned that
once there was a critical mass
of diversity in the
classroom you had a much more
interesting conversation.
And it was also very
educational for the students
to find themselves
in a situation
where there was more
than a critical mass.
Now, when I came to Harvard,
Harvard had a bigger
critical mass.
So really the last time I taught
my R and B soul class, about --
at least 40% of the class
was African-American,
maybe about 40% was white,
and the rest was
African-American and Hispanic.
So there was a real
diverse group of people.
So I really tried
to teach it in a way
that the African-Americans
felt like their side
of the story was going
to be the predominant one
and the white students
had to deal with it.
And many of them do and
rise to the occasion.
And they're a self-selecting
group of the white students.
If you don't -- you know,
I teach it as an
African-American studies class
so they know that they're
going to have to deal with race
when they come to the class.
So it's a self-selecting group
of people who want to do that.
But I really try to get them
to engage with one another
and have the teaching sections,
have honest conversations
about these issues.
Now, in some cases
there are flare ups
on various things
that the TF's handle.
>> Larry Appelbaum: For example?
>> Ingrid Monson: There --
What's come up in
terms of hip-hop is
that the African-American
students really don't want
to see the white kids
singing along to songs
with the N word in them.
And many of the white students
were going I'm just singing
along to this song.
It's on the, you know.
So, having a debate
about that, for example.
And that's something that's
changed since, you know,
nobody -- the prevalence
of that word
in some hip-hop has created
a different discussion
around this.
I would manage feelings of
students who would say, well,
you're talking about all this
African-American history,
you're excluding
the white musicians.
Okay, so this becomes
then a conversation
about let's examine exclusion
here for a minute and who is --
who experiences exclusion
in this society
and what that's about.
And, you know, it's
not like I don't teach
about any white musicians, you
know, but that I try to put it
in the context of this in the
very racially unequal structure
of the music industry in
the early 20th century.
So, you know, trying to talk
about Benny Goodman in a way
that says that, look,
by the standards
of his time he was
a progressive.
But a later generation would
look back and say, well,
this is an example of
white appropriation.
He took Fletcher
Henderson's arrangement
and he became a rich
person on the air
and the black bands couldn't
get the sponsored radio.
So I try to get them to
have a more complex view.
I don't want them
to just say, okay,
Benny Goodman is
just an exploiter.
I want them to see the dynamic
about what gave him white
privilege in that situation.
And so, why it's natural
that some other people
were resentful of that.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Do you ever
get kind of negative feedback
about a white woman teaching
about African-American culture?
>> Ingrid Monson: Oh yeah, yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
You still get that?
>> Ingrid Monson: That's okay.
Well, they -- it comes with the
-- it comes with the territory.
And I think any white person
who's working with this is,
you just have to expect
that there's going
to be some ambivalence,
and that's okay.
And I've had, you know,
at the same time I've had
that I've also had
wonderful experiences
of people really
warmly responding to me,
African-American scholars
and students and things
that I wouldn't give up
for anything, and sometimes
that I've been surprised by.
So they're both sides of things.
I think, you know, it
matters, your attitude matters
and attitude of respect
matters and attitude
of knowing what you're
talking about helps.
Even so, you know, I try to say
to my students I'm not trying
to tell you to think just
like I do about this.
This is why I think about it.
You know, here's why
I think what I think.
It may look different
to your generation.
You need to have these
conversations among yourselves
about this.
At the same time, you know,
sometimes I feel very white
standing up there going,
here I am, going on
about issues of race,
music, and culture again.
And I try to tell myself, and I
think the good part of this is,
I often tell my students,
you know,
that one of the things
I've always been interested
in exploring is like what
would an ethical relationship
to African-American
music and culture be?
I'm not saying I'm it, but
I'm saying that I would
like to be more like that, okay.
So I think being
honest about that
as a white person
you have privilege.
You know, and being aware
of that and, you know,
mentioning all the cont
-- you know, every --
you know, every -- you know, one
thing I've said to the students,
everybody, you know, how
come everybody wants access
to the good parts
of African-American
culture, the fun parts.
They want access to the music
and they say you won't
let me, you know.
And so they'll lay this trip on
African-American musicians, oh,
you're excluding
me, excluding me.
Nobody wants the privilege
to be profiled on the --
on the New Jersey Turnpike.
Nobody wants the privilege
of having lousy schools
in their neighborhood, you know.
So I try to get the
non-African-Americans to think
about if you really want to
appreciate, it's not just
about appreciating the music,
it's about appreciating
the people and the culture.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So as
you encourage your students
to have their own conversations
and to work with these concepts,
are you ever surprised
by their insights?
Do they come up with
new things each year?
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes, they do.
I mean, and I could write
a whole thing about,
especially in the smaller
courses I teach where I get
to read all their papers.
Some of the students
write amazing things.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I
mean, are you surprised
by what they come up with?
>> Ingrid Monson: I'm having
trouble thinking of, you know,
one single example
that can show you.
But, one of my -- I had a
student when I first came
to Harvard, and he's
now in our faculty.
His name is Brandon Terry.
He's a political scientist.
And I taught my jazz class,
and I think it was the one
where Nat Hentoff came, and he
wrote the most amazing paper.
Of course, this is
about 12 years ago
so I can't tell you exactly
what the paper was about.
It was extremely well written.
Then I had -- then I
taught another class
where we did Motown and --
Motown had the manners
lady, Mrs. --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Oh, the one
who taught all the groups
how to behave and --
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes, you
know, and she taught Marvin Gaye
to not close his eyes while
he's singing, you know.
Well, he traced her
down in Detroit
and did a phone interview
with her --
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Great, great.
>> Ingrid Monson: About it so.
>> Larry Appelbaum: There
was also Cholly Atkins,
we used to --
>> Ingrid Monson: Cholly
Atkins, the dancer.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Teach
him choreography, yeah.
That was cool stuff.
>> Ingrid Monson:
You know, and then,
so the students sometimes would
have the idea that Motown, okay,
they were just trying
to act white.
And I've always thought
that's kind of unfair, okay,
given what, you know, they
were -- this was the --
a really successful business.
And, yes, they systematically --
they strategically tried
to do it so it would --
so it would make it
into the mainstream,
and brilliantly it did.
>> Larry Appelbaum: The
sound of Young America.
>> Ingrid Monson: And The Funk
Brothers and James Jamerson.
There's, you know, that's
not a compromise with,
you know, musical sound.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
But you've mentioned --
>> Ingrid Monson: You
know, but the students do.
You know, they ask questions
that you don't expect
and you respond to it
and sometimes it
can be fun doing it.
And when you're on
it's really fun.
Some days you're not on.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Do you like
to be challenged as a professor?
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes,
it depends on the
kind of challenge.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Respectful?
>> Ingrid Monson: Well, yeah,
if I feel like I'm being
insulted then it's a drag.
But I won't lash out at them no
matter how insulting they are.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Do
they try and bait you?
>> Ingrid Monson: Not often.
Not often.
Now, what -- most of them are
usually pretty respectful.
But if I say something
they disagree with,
then I try to deal with it
and listen to them, and I may
or may not agree with
their point of view,
may think they're being unfair.
If I feel like the reaction
-- what I'm getting is sexist,
I get a little icy [laughter].
>> Larry Appelbaum:
I would imagine.
>> Ingrid Monson: Okay, so.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah,
this is not surprising, yeah.
So do you think your students,
or students at Harvard are
typical of students everywhere?
I mean, are students students?
>> Ingrid Monson: In many ways I
do think students are students.
You know, we do have
some extraordinary,
extraordinary undergraduates
at Harvard
that can completely
blow your mind.
And then there are
others who are, you know,
no matter how smart they
are they're still kids.
They're still 18,
19, 20 years old
and they have all the
potential in the world,
but they don't know
all that much yet.
But I also found that I had
wonderful students when I taught
at Washington University
in St. Louis, when I taught
at the University of
Michigan, when I taught
at the University
of Chicago, okay.
So I haven't taught at any
school that was a, you know,
you know, all those
schools are good schools.
But I do think that students
can get overly obsessed
about what going to a particular
school means about them.
Because there's plenty of
students at the University
of Wisconsin, for
example, who are as good
as any Harvard student.
You know, and there have
been studies about this.
There's an economist at
Stanford who did work
on Caroline [assumed spelling],
what's her, something with an H,
who did a systematic study
of what people's SAT's were
in all kinds of public schools,
Chicago, Detroit, you know,
the whole -- the whole country.
And the interesting thing was
that many of the working class
and inner-city neighborhoods,
there were plenty of kids
that had scores that would
be competitive for getting
into a top school,
but not as many
of those students
applied to those schools.
So I think that there are plenty
of students across the country,
and I think an earlier
generation
of African-American students,
and I think like about somebody
like Anthony Braxton or
people who were in the AACM,
they went to like Roosevelt
University and Chicago,
or Governors State
University, you know,
less prestigious schools,
but they got themselves
very educated.
So I'm against the
snobbery about the schools.
And the problem with
Harvard is --
I shouldn't say.
I shouldn't say this on
camera [laughter], okay.
Well, it's -- they
get a little were
over invested in their brand.
But I'm the ben -- I have to
say, I'm the beneficiary of that
so I can't complain too much.
They pay -- they make
my life possible.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
You used the word,
did you use the word snobbery?
Was that something
you just mentioned?
Anyway, I'm curious if you
think there's an intelligentsia
in jazz?
>> Ingrid Monson:
Oh, yeah, absolutely.
Jazz is an intelligentsia
in some ways.
>> Larry Appelbaum: But
who are they actually
and what do they do?
>> Ingrid Monson: Okay.
Well, I think, you know --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Are
they just gatekeepers or no?
>> Ingrid Monson:
Well, I don't know.
It's interesting.
I mean, there -- jazz has always
had the self-confidence to sort
of understand that
it's important.
And that in order to
become the musicians that --
musicians became they
had to be, you know,
they had to work
really hard and they had
to learn a lot of things.
And they became interested
in trying to be artists.
I mean, the path of getting jazz
recognized as an art was a --
was a movement in many ways.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Does
this really start with bebop
or were people self-aware --
>> Ingrid Monson: Well, there's
bebop, no, it's happening --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Even before?
>> Ingrid Monson: Before that.
You know, Armstrong
and Ellington are no
slouches along these lines.
>> Larry Appelbaum: No, I'm just
talking about the awareness,
the self-awareness
not only as artists.
>> Ingrid Monson: It becomes
more pronounced after bebop,
but I, you know, I
think someone, you know,
someone like Coleman Hawkins or,
it evolved with the time of it.
So there's an insider quality of
talk among the jazz community,
however you define it.
And I think of the jazz
community as being comprised
of musicians, of people
who run clubs, of critics,
of presenters, and
audience, you know,
members who are devoted
and they come.
I always used to marvel when I
lived in New York and when I was
in graduate school that you
would go to Bradley's or any one
of the clubs, and the same
people were at these concerts,
or jazz, you know, this was
before jazz at Lincoln Center.
This was, you know, you
know, even the concerts
that would happen
at Carnegie Hall or,
you would see the
same people there
and you would see
the critics there.
And I remember going to,
you know, for example,
I remember going to an Ornette
concert at Carnegie Hall.
And the first half
was a Japanese singer
who Ornette was promoting
in some kind of way
and trying to give a chance.
Well, let's just say that the
New York jazz audience wasn't
responding that well.
Everybody sort of left
and went to the bar
and came back -- came back out.
But you would see those -- you
would see those same people.
So within this very large
multimillion city there was a
small town feeling about
the people who came
out to the jazz concerts.
And I think we've
always really liked that,
but it is kind of insular.
And other people think
we're snobs, you know,
or there is such thing as
a jazz snob that, you know,
there's a certain kind of
person you're talking to,
a record collector, and unless,
you know, so I have Mingus',
Charles Mingus presents
Charles Mingus.
And the other one has,
well, I have a, you know,
and a recitation of record
numbers and everything.
And usually we're just being
excited about what we're doing.
But there is a little
ranking thing that --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Sure.
>> Ingrid Monson: That goes on.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
The matrix boys.
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes,
the matrix numbers boys.
And I always felt like --
and then sometimes there
was this certain kind
of male conversation
that would go on,
that no matter how much
I tried to insert myself
in the conversation they
were talking to each other
and I was [inaudible].
>> Larry Appelbaum: Well, isn't
collecting a male impulse,
or am I being sexist there?
>> Ingrid Monson: Well, if you
talk to Krin Gabbard he will say
to you that -- say that
it is a male impulse.
Sherry Tucker is a collector.
And so Sherry would argue
with Krin that, you know,
there was nothing in your DNA
that made you a collector.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
It's just when you go
to certain communities,
if you circulate --
>> Ingrid Monson:
Yes, that jazz --
>> Larry Appelbaum: You'll see
that it's somewhat
predominantly --
>> Ingrid Monson: It is guys.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Male.
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
And some are not so.
And even within the
jazz community at large,
there are sub-communities
based on different genre.
>> Ingrid Monson: Oh yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So
it's not as if somebody
who likes jazz likes all
different kinds of jazz.
>> Ingrid Monson: That's right.
Now, I'm the kind that likes
all different kinds of jazz.
I sort of feel like being
a scholar makes you want
to advocate for all of that.
And I want to see the whole
of the music represented.
When you're an artist I think
though you cultivate developing
your own voice and you
want to advocate for that,
for that place within it.
So if you are a successful,
experimental musician you're
going to argue for that
and you're kind of going to
look down your nose at somebody
who does something else, or at
least that's been my experience.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So I'm
guessing you, like many people
in this country,
are paying attention
to what's happening
politically among other ways
to think about it.
And we know that there's
been some discussion floating
about around the possible
pulling of funding
for the National Endowment for
the Arts, the National Endowment
for the Humanities, and other
agencies, especially agencies
that work with culture.
And I wonder what, how
important is government support
for the arts and to what extent
do the arts really matter
in people's lives?
>> Ingrid Monson: Well,
I think the arts are
extremely important.
This will not surprise you.
And I'm horrified at
the idea of the NEA
and the NEH being defunded.
First of all, it's a
relatively small amount
of the federal budget already.
And I think what
people don't realize is
that the various grants and
programs that are sponsored
by the NEH are really, really
important in a number of ways.
I think to presenting
agencies where they, you know,
just getting part
of their funding
from the NEA makes them
more credible to fundraising
from other kinds of
foundations and organizations
to put together a program.
We need to -- when you look,
they have entire ministries
of culture and things that are
about supporting their
cultural efforts.
The NEH, I mean, humanity
scholars are always applying
for those grants.
They're very competitive grants.
They have an extremely
good track record
of producing excellent
scholarship.
They have a wonderful digital
humanities initiative as part
of it, and we need these things.
You know, overall with the
change in the politics,
the thing that is
most discouraging
to me is the deep
anti-intellectualism.
The deep anti-knowledge of this.
The fact that people don't
seem to care about the truth.
They just care about
manipulating discourse
to get what they want
is what seems to be --
is happening these days and
I think that is horrifying.
What we try to do in
scholarship is present ideas
and cite your sources
where you got them.
That, you know, be able to show
where you got your facts from so
that somebody else can come and
take a look at it and revisit it
and see it in a different
way, if they so believe.
And I think those kind
of research skills are really
important for students.
So I feel it's, you know, it's
not only the NEA and the NEH
that are under attack, but
all of higher education.
I think there has been,
as if to be educated
and know things is
simply East Coast snobbery
or something, or
liberal snobbery.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Or elitism.
>> Ingrid Monson: Or elitism.
And the thing is, I don't
like elitism of a --
well, when I say elitism I think
that when somebody is just
being arbitrarily hierarchical.
And I don't think that's
what real scholarship is.
I think what scholarship is is
learning deeply about something
and be able to present
and defend your position,
and that's part of being an
educated person in the world.
That's part of what we need
in all forms of leadership.
So when I hear we have a
president that doesn't read
and instead watches TV,
that really disturbs me.
How can we get informed, smart
policies such that has always,
you know, been happening
within the federal government,
you know, I mean at its best.
So the idea that
reading and writing
or the arts aren't
important, you know,
is deeply disturbing to me.
And I think that presidents of
universities are trying to speak
out at our own university.
Our own president is very
supportive of the arts.
We don't always have
enough money to do things,
but I feel like President
Faust gets that.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Good.
I want to address something.
I think we have a
little bit of time left.
You're going to give your talk,
your lecture, on Thursday night.
What will the topic be?
>> Ingrid Monson:
It's called Miles
and Coltrane as Living
Ancestors.
And it's part of
their 90th birthday.
And it's, the talk is really
my attempt to try to talk
about them in a way that tries
to bring something
new to the table.
Now, it's very difficult to say
anything new about Miles Davis
and John Coltrane, and so I
try to contextualize them --
>> Larry Appelbaum: What
does that mean, by the way,
to contextualize them?
>> Ingrid Monson: Oh, that's
one of those academic words.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Oh, sorry.
>> Ingrid Monson: To fill
in the historical context,
to put it within a framework.
And what I'm doing is I'm
talking about them as being
like living ancestors
and African religions,
which are examples of
divinities, but divinities
with individual personalities,
divinities with flaw,
just like the Greek gods are,
you know, or Hindu gods are
that way, and to really
try to get at what it feels
like to listen to
Miles and Coltrane
and why we lose our
critical distance when we're
in the act of listening to this.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Thirty-five
years ago I interviewed Archie
Shepp and I asked
him at the time one
of my more naive questions, what
do you think Coltrane, you know,
what do you think about him now?
What would have happened to him
if he had lived beyond his 40's?
And he said, John Coltrane
would be an old man standing
by the side of the road
with a stick in his hand.
That elder.
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes, exactly.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Ingrid Monson: Absolutely.
Well, I have some
fun tidbits in there.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Ingrid Monson: And I kind of
contrast the two personalities
because they were very
different personalities,
both absolute pivotal
to the music
and inspiring deep devotion by
many different kinds of people.
>> Larry Appelbaum: How much
of that devotion is based
in mythology versus reality?
Not that these are
mutually exclusive.
>> Ingrid Monson: Well,
they're both there.
People's investment
in the mythology part I
really feel is deeply related
to their listening
experience of it, okay.
So, I've got some examples
in this lecture, for example,
of Amiri Baraka responding
to listening to Miles
and an essay he wrote
after Miles died.
I have materials showing
different people viewing them
as models of different things.
And, you know, look,
I'm a scholar.
I want to -- part of being
a scholar is breaking
down mythologies, but I think
you have to look at both
where they come from and look
at people's investment in them
as part of how they
are as fans in this.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
But people want
to believe what they
want to believe.
>> Ingrid Monson:
That's true, they do.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And they
don't want to be distracted
by nuance necessarily or
by the things that are --
don't celebrate them
as much, you know,
because everybody is human.
>> Ingrid Monson:
Right, exactly.
We'd much rather
have a positive story
about ourselves, so
I understand that.
And you walk a line when you're
trying to write about some
of these famous people
of if you break
down their mythology
are you hurting them?
And I took the position
in my Freedom Sounds book
that you've got to have
that nuance in there
that if it's just all
celebratory you lose the story
of how hard it was for them
to become who they were.
And I think I mentioned
this the other day,
but I really view music
as a means of self-making
and that the towering
figures in this were --
did an amazing job of
that, and that's one
of the reasons they're
so admired.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Is there also a risk
at romanticizing the struggle?
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes, of course
you can roman -- yes, you can --
you can romanticize
it and, you know,
and never be critical
of the person.
I don't believe in that either.
So, you have to have a balance.
Well, nobody's perfect,
that's my --
>> Larry Appelbaum: No,
everybody struggles.
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes, okay.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
And that's what --
>> Ingrid Monson:
Nobody's perfect.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Helps us connect.
>> Ingrid Monson: And everybody
has things they've done
that they're ashamed
of, and that's true
for great artists just as
it is for everybody else.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So,
you know, forgive me,
but I'm thinking about Miles
right now, and Coltrane
for that matter, and
people tend to, I mean,
part of what makes Miles such
a contemporary figure still,
and it's not just this movie
that came out last year,
it has less to do with his music
and more to do with who he was
and the culture and
what he represented.
And so I wonder which
aspects draw you in?
What are you most taken
with when it comes
to somebody like Miles Davis?
>> Ingrid Monson: Well,
someone like Miles --
>> Ingrid Monson: Is it --
is it the music itself or --
>> Ingrid Monson: Well,
it's music from me.
You know, he had, you know,
and I'll talk about this
on Thursday, he had
this more rebellious,
trickster type quality
to his persona.
He always dressed really
well and thought about it.
He looked cool and everything.
And Baraka has this [inaudible]
so he's just going
rapturous over, you know,
how Miles Davis looks.
You know, so I think for men,
you know, he was a certain kind
of a model of a kind of a
modern African-American, cool,
hip jazz guy who wasn't
going to bow down.
And so modeled a kind of
resistance to what was expected
of him that was widely admired,
and women admired it, too.
The underside of Miles,
of course, is he was --
he was really awful to the
women he was involved with.
And that's the, you know, that's
an underside of the story.
And he could be mean
and mercurial
and generous one moment.
I mean, Herbie Hancock writes
about him in his autobiography
in very interesting -- he talked
about how generous
he was musically,
but in other respects
not so much.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
So a complex man.
>> Ingrid Monson: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And
you contrast that, perhaps,
with John Coltrane,
whose music is complex,
and yet as a person he seems
not quite as multidimensional.
Is that fair to say?
>> Ingrid Monson: Oh,
I wouldn't say that.
I would say that he didn't care
about whether he was wearing the
latest, cool looking clothes.
I mean, that many
people reported, in fact,
he didn't always wear
very nice clothes at all.
But, he had a lot of humility,
whereas Miles had more
of an arrogant quality to him,
or could come across that way.
And Coltrane was very much
into spiritual stuff and trying
to be a good person,
and that seemed
to be a central mission for him.
And he surrounded himself
with people who had
that same interest,
like Alice Coltrane.
And then I look at him and he
brought Alice into his music,
brought her into the band
and wanted her to be a part
of his creative life,
which may have made some
of his previous band
members unhappy.
But that's what he chose.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Your
favorite Miles record,
your favorite Coltrane record?
I'll put you on the spot here.
>> Ingrid Monson: It's hard.
But I suppose if I have
to name one album --
>> Larry Appelbaum: You
can name two if you like.
>> Ingrid Monson:
Okay [laughter].
>> Larry Appelbaum: Feel free.
>> Ingrid Monson: Is the
Miles Davis, My Funny Val --
what was originally the
My Funny Valentine album
that was recorded in 1964
that has this amazing version
of My Funny Valentine and Stella
by Starlight, and also happened
to be a benefit concert for a
coalition of civil rights group
for voters' rights,
February 12, 1964.
And it's the quintet with
Wayne [assumed spelling] --
well, actually, George Coleman
is on this one and Ron Carter
and Tony Williams
and Herbie Hancock.
That's a great one.
Now, of Coltrane.
I like so many of them.
I mean, like everybody
else, I love Supreme,
but I also love Crescent.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
It's a good one.
>> Ingrid Monson: And I also
like Expression of
his later ones.
>> Larry Appelbaum: It's
always interesting when you --
when somebody says they love
Miles or they love Coltrane.
I always say which records?
>> Ingrid Monson: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Because
they have distinct periods --
>> Ingrid Monson: They
have distinct periods.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
In their career.
>> Ingrid Monson: I mean, I
also love the earlier Miles.
If I liked the earlier
1956 My Funny Valentine,
Around Midnight album, the
Jazz at the Plaza album,
the Sketches of Spain.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Yeah, [inaudible].
>> Ingrid Monson: I mean, an
incredibly rich, musical legacy.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Well,
there's a reason why these
records never go out of print.
>> Ingrid Monson: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
In the time remaining I want to
ask you as a musician, but also,
especially as a scholar and
as an educator and author,
how do you measure success?
>> Ingrid Monson: How
do I measure success?
I think a really feeling
of success can't come
completely from external stuff.
It's got to become -- come
from an internal feeling
of like you're doing your best.
You like how you've developed
over the course of your life.
It's nice.
I feel very fortunate
that I have the external
success that I've had.
I couldn't believe it when I was
hired at Harvard in this chair
and sort of the excitement
about my work among an
audience has surprised me.
And I, of course,
have enjoyed that.
But, you know, I do feel
like what got me there is I've
always been trying, you know,
driven by trying to
do the best that I can
and to bring the best part
of whatever skills I
have to bear on this.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Dr. Ingrid Monson,
continued success to you.
>> Ingrid Monson:
Okay, thank you.
It's been a pleasure
to talk with you.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Yeah, always.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.